daniel craig and james corden teamed up  on the late late show for a hilarious  reenactment of 24 blockbuster movies in  just 10 minutes it's so impressive they  kicked things off with jurassic park  with daniel craig putting on his best  richard attenborough impression take it  away guys  welcome to jurassic park you did it you  crazy son of a  you did it  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  [Applause]  [Music]  we got to stop this baby  no don't stand by 50. you slow down on  this whole box we'll explore  [Applause]  [Music]  family  family and cars and family  [Applause]  well  this car could be  systematic  how  dramatic all traumatic  why could be greece  [Applause]  [Music]  you're gonna need a bigger boat  [Applause]  [Music]  i'll never let go jack  there's actually quite a lot of room on  it  there it is isn't that